bill de blasio mayor of new york on
board the other day waiting for his
dealer to arrive so he tried to cancel
the
tribute to 911 because coronavirus
people noticed they were outraged
canceling the 911 memorial
so he reversed course but bill de blasio
is still
a big fan of shutting down things that
people enjoy and particularly traditions
that have been around for a long time he
hates the past
so he's trying again de blasio announced
that the macy's thanksgiving day parade
won't really be a parade this year there
won't even be a live procession but de
blasio is apparently too high to realize
that people that might not like this
watch de blasio enthusiastically sell
the
new format for the thanksgiving parade
it will not be the same parade we're
used to it will be a different kind of
event they're reinventing the event
for this moment in history and you will
be able to feel the spirit and the joy
of that day
on television online not a live parade
but something that will really give us
that warmth and that great feeling we
have on thanksgiving day
they're reinventing this event for this
moment in history we're thinking indica
not sativa he seems kind of subdued
meanwhile new york is reinventing its
crime statistics for this moment in
history hundreds of corporations
based in new york are pleading with the
mayor to crack down on crime and
save the city improve quality of life
care about the people
who actually live there and pay for all
of this nonsense
is he responding in any way seth barron
lives in new york he's associate editor
at city journal
he joins us tonight seth thanks so much
for coming on
so people have confronted stakeholders
as i think they're called in the city
have confronted de blasio about this
what have they said and what's his
response been
well they're just begging him to take
leadership and seize the moment and try
to fix the city
but as you see he kind of has these
feckless responses i mean the macy's day
parade is a good example
uh you know this is an extremely popular
national event
people tune in and it signals you know
if we were to have it it would signal
hey new york city wants tourists maybe
we can't have everyone now but
you know we're open for business this is
what the future holds
uh de blasio anything that's like
cheerful
and wholesome that normal people like
he frowns on he wants to squash because
you know
people like that will will obey the law
meanwhile in washington square park
every weekend
refuse fascism which is part of the
revolutionary communists has a protest
party with a dj
and hundreds of people drinking doing
drugs
dancing de blasio doesn't even notice it
so he implicitly
tacitly is permitting it yeah drag queen
story hour for third grader still
in progress of course needless to say
has de blasio ever built anything
or does he only destroy i'm just asking
because he is symbolic of the left
very good at wrecking things that other
people built very bad at building
anything has he built anything anything
um that's a good question uh he had a
plan to
extend the uh the shoreline of manhattan
into the east river
uh i don't think that's gonna happen um
no
i can't really say that he's built very
much you know he's poured public money
into
rehabbing uh some apartments
uh but i couldn't say that he's big on
building things he's more on big on
redistribution that's that's what he
sees as his
his metier is taking what other people
have
and giving it to to others yeah with him
in control
right exactly it's the opposite of
charity forcing other people to give
it's not true right seth barron a keen
observer of new york city good luck
there
thank you thank you tucker